hello everyone welcome to our keynote
presentation ataxia dis me tree of
thought and the cerebellar cognitive
affective syndrome presented by dr.
Jeremy douche Mountain dr. Stromm is a
professor of neurology at Harvard
Medical School and a neurologist at the
Massachusetts General Hospital where he
is the founding director since 1994 of
the ataxia unit director of the
laboratory for neuroanatomy and
cerebellar neurobiology and a member of
the cognitive behavioral neurology unit
dr. Sean's research and clinical
practice focuses on neurology and basic
science of the ataxias and other
cerebellar disorders and he has
pioneered the role of the cerebellum and
cognition and emotion I am Samantha
Pierce the clinical research coordinator
and the shaman lab and I'll be the
moderator for this presentation we are
delighted to bring me the education web
seminar presented by lab roots lab Bruce
is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
the screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen if you have a trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the help desk button located on the
promotional board at the bottom or
center of your screen or use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Jeremy Roman I
will now turn the presentation over to
him thank you Sam and thank you lab
roots for the opportunity
resent this worked in the neuroscience
community I'm here to tell you what has
turned out to be a remarkable story
about the cerebellum and its role in
nervous system function the title of the
talk ataxia
dysmetria and the cerebellar cognitive
affective syndrome encapsulate how we've
gone from cerebellum as motor control
device the cerebellum with a much wider
range of involvement in nervous system
and repertoires of behavior just to
start off with the disclosures include
some books that you may find to be
helpful in your local library to talk
about cerebellar anatomy neurobiology
and the cerebellar diseases some of the
work of me described describing include
some of the licensed work of scales of
used here at Mass General Hospital and
the consulting relates to drug companies
about finally coming to the table with
pharmaceutical agents to try and help
improve the lives of patients with
cerebellar inherited pay taxes and other
forms the story starts with our teaching
from many years ago that the cerebellar
syndrome is a tattoo ataxia of gait
dysmetria of the extremities in
coordination of control of the arms and
the legs speech problems or the Safia
and the range of ocular motor
impairments and these would describe us
some of the great names in the history
of neurology Sanger Brown P Emery
Felix Babinski and Gordon Holmes who's
examination we still use today in the
assessment of the cerebellar motor
syndrome so let me show you some cases
of ataxia that gives you a sense of what
the cerebellar motor syndrome is the
first is as German with a gauge
impairment wide-based
staggering and
Gate typical of cerebellar ataxia the
next is the heel the shin test where one
sees the jerkiness side to side
movements and instability as one slides
the heel down the opposite shin this is
a demonstration of a young woman having
difficulty with the control of the
extremity as she reaches from her nose
to my finger end point this metria and
oscillation at the elbow and then we
have some problems with the speech
[Music]
derived by difficulty with articulation
and clarity in particular this young
woman's story exemplifies the problem
with cerebellum as pure motor control
device at the age of 14 she had a
cerebellar hemorrhage from a rupture of
a vascular malformation and for the next
two years she had difficulty with a
variety of behaviors she was not able to
speak she didn't swallow
she had a feeding tube placed she was
unable to keep her clothes on all the
time and tried to disrobe she had some
aggressions and striking out and along
with all of this it was only a mild
cerebellar tremor and what one sees on
the imaging is of the cerebral
hemisphere upstairs looks quite normal
but there's mark disruption of the
cerebellar anatomy as a result of these
cerebellar
hemorrhage this case encapsulate the
problem with explaining cerebellum
purely as a motor control device so let
me take you through the story as how we
go from Sarah Pettis into them equals
attacks yet to the cerebellar motifs in
Rome
and we'll talk about what the rest of
cerebellum does as we now know from the
series of experiments that have been
performed over the years I came to this
question from patients with strokes in
the deep parts of the brain this first
one is a stroke in the genu of the
internal capsule that disrupts the
discussion between frontal lobe and
thalamus and this patient had a neglect
syndrome had difficulty drawing on the
left side of the page only focusing on
the right trouble join the clock ignored
the left side of a star had difficulty
placing cities and states on a
rudimentary map of the u.s. in a
remarkably fragmented image of a person
and the second case was one that was
then part of a series of patient's
caught eight strokes exemplified by the
stroke right there in whom there was a
neglect syndrome also of the
contralateral space these are
hemispheric syndromes journey from the
parietal lobe resulting from strokes
deep down in the brain and my question
at that time in the early 1980s was if
these syndromes can produce behavioral
changes from areas that thought were
purely motor control what then could be
the story about cerebellum the big motor
control region Tom in the in Africa
toriel regions the story of that goes
back a long time this has been chenza
melech army who in 1776 published his
monograph that described the major
anatomical features of the cerebellum
what we have subsequently tend to learn
from the translations of Italian
scientists who looked at his papers is
that Nana Connie was interested in the
cerebellum because of his question about
the relationship or the number of phobia
in the cerebrum and the level of
intelligence so the very first story the
sifting cerebellar anatomy and
energy was the promoted by the question
of cerebellum and its relationship not
to motor control but to higher function
the field then was influenced by Franz
Joseph gall who we may know from
phrenology but he was in fact a
spectacular anatomist and people came
from far and wide to see his two
sections as identified here in the Atlas
of Golden Spur time in 1810 Francis of
CO also believed that the cerebellum was
critical for sexual behavior and in fact
he wrote a monograph on the functions of
the cerebellum in which sexual
proclivity and cerebellum were felt to
be a hand in glove and this idea led to
the questioning of the hypothesis by a
man called Marie Jean Piaf Loretta C was
a joint of Neurosciences in his day and
Florence questioned goals ideas and he
did this in an experimental map he
appeared on pigeons he damaged the
cerebellum and he showed that whereas
Rolando had suggested that the
cerebellum is important for movement and
power Lorenz concluded that the
cerebellum is important for coordination
that moved pigeons could flap their
wings but they couldn't actually do it
in a coordinator now know Florence also
believed that the cerebellum was the
same everywhere and every Park could do
everything was the idea of a clean
potentiality and from this time the
cerebellum has been thought of as a
critical for and exclusive only for
motor control of balanced equilibrium
and the cerebellar motor simcha let me
jump forward then to what we think about
as the ways the cerebral hemispheres
organized in the way that the nervous
system functions in contemporary
neuroscience terminology we now think
about the brain as a distributed neural
system comprising anatomic
regions were nodes distributed around
the brain each with architectonic
properties unique to that region links
together in a precise manner while
working in concert to produce the
ultimate behavior pattern well that's
all good and well except you can see
from all these drive-ins is a big
missing part down the bottom so from my
perspective if you turn the brain upside
down cerebellum now becomes front and
center and that's what I want to talk
about and they remained a lot of time
together today like to run through some
of the essential anatomical features of
cerebellar organization when you look at
this which I encourage you to do both
here in 1999 you can get a sense of
these cerebellar fissures they both here
would separate these cerebellar lobules
and one can identify the anterior load
in front of the primary fissure in
relatively smaller in comparison to the
much larger got a posterior which has
expanded massively through revolution we
have the cerebellar cortex the deep
white matter and the nuclei situated
deep within these cerebellar substance
and we can now look at this in
coordinate space allowing us to study
sir about a functional imaging in a way
that is much more precise than we
previously way to do so the second
aspect of dividing the cerebellar gross
topography attention of pustule of and a
third region called flocculonodular lobe
is the fact that they said by the
histology at the level of the cortex
under the microscope is essentially
homogeneous throughout that stands in
contrast to our understanding of these
cerebral cortex which has multiple
different areas the Tri lamina cortex
going back to the Nobel prize-winning
work of Santiago Ramon to how more than
a hundred
shows that we have the city cerebellar
molecular the Purkinje there between the
autumn air and in a granular layer seen
over here and the pattern of the
organization of cortex is essentially
consistent throughout we can identify
some of the fibers in the cerebellar
cortex now with the new imaging as we
showed a few years ago to show the
different foreign organization of the
fiber in the cerebellar molecular of the
parallel fibers and the inter neurons in
the cerebellar cortex
interestingly and less well-known is
that Paris had four zonation within the
Sarabande and these are important
principles about anatomy that have
relevance for the way the brain is
structured we know from the work of yun
both came back to the 1960s that there
is a power saddle donation in the
cerebellar white matter and using a
monoclonal antibody stain there is a
pair of cervical donation in the
cerebellar cortex as well as even
positive and zebra negative bands that
map onto a cortical projection to the
server of the nuclei and quarter of
ejections from the inferior Oliveri
nucleo this is a parasternal
organization both in terms of the
histology under chemistry and
another important principle then back to
the 1940s is the definitive
determination that the echo potentiality
idea of Lorenz was inaccurate and this
is the work of smiler and colleagues in
which we identify that with the
flattened map of the cerebellum and a
monkey or a cat the legs are up the
front the arms for the back the head and
neck at the posterior vermis of the
cerebellum and the second representation
down here in the para median mobula what
we now call dog you at eight furthermore
there is a representation of the visual
and the auditory system both from the
cerebral cortex down and from the
periphery in landing up in the posterior
aspect of being Sarah Dora verse there
are a few important points from this
very study now one the fact that the map
that we see of the representations of
the arms and legs in fact was a sensory
map from which was derived the motor
topography to sensory mapping study
secondly the visual and auditory input
that smiler to complete to include back
in the nineteen forties and fifties that
there was something more about certain
elements of the motor control and in
retrospect now also can tell is that
this large area that is silent in terms
of the inputs from the periphery is in
the old terminology what one would have
thought of as the silent frontal lobe
there is no somatosensory or motor
representation in the lateral parts of
the cerebral hemispheres so that beats
the question what in fact is going on
there for the pediatricians in the
audience it's important to remember that
the cerebellar growth on MRI takes off
markedly in the third trimester so the
surname is growing both in the third
trimester and also in post nationwide so
it's ongoing development even after
birth in a remarkably strong way when I
came to the question of cerebellum and
his role in
higher-order function I teamed up with
the man who became a mentor a teacher of
the panga on the great neuroanatomists
of the last century and slapped the
pantheon I made injections of traces in
the cerebral cortex of the monkey and we
traced these pathways into the white
matter and down into the brain stem
where they terminate in the ponds the
reason that we did this was to question
whether there is a pathway linking the
association areas of the cerebral
Hemisphere as important for high water
function with the cortical quanta
cerebellar system the cerebral cortex
focuser them by way of at one time
nuclei and the cerebellum and gets
information back to the cerebral cortex
way of the cortical dynamic projection
so the first step in the circuit is the
cortical entire pathway has ejection of
tracer and terminations in the pons
this is a summary diagram that many
years of work which shows that there is
a relationship between the green regions
here at least the motor areas of
cerebral cortex damage the pons this is
rostral down to the portal pumps and the
green of that presented more on the
portal funds of the monkey whereas there
are projections from the prefrontal
cortices the positive arrival cortices
in blue the superior temporal regions in
red and the perestroika compared the
kappa leaves in an orange all
terminating in the pawns and they do so
with a mosaic of topographically
arranged projections so what we now know
is that there are areas involved in
planning organizing and thinking
strategy formation and working memory
spatial organization and spatial
awareness language processing visual
place memory limbic circuitry here in
the singular charge which we haven't
shown you all getting information into
the pons and from there goes directly
into cerebellum through the little
peanut so this was the first
demonstration of high order areas from
the cerebral cortex
getting information
to the sir government it ought to be
processed now the system has a feedback
as well and the work of a strict and his
colleagues using the trans synaptic
traces superimposed upon previous work
of singles tracer studies showing that
if you make injections of a tracer in
the motor cortex of the monkey the are
neurons labeled in the dorsal part of
the server of dentate nucleus and the
inter positive nucleus but if you make
an injection of the trace led going back
down to cerebellum for the prefrontal
cortex the neurons labeled in this step
at a nuclei are in the dentate in the
more ventral and lateral region so there
is a feedback system as well as the
feed-forward system but not ready to
motor regions but to non motor areas as
well and if you then match up these
renal cortical areas with areas in the
cerebellum itself the motor cortex
everyone is talking to the anterior lobe
Davos three four five and partially but
row six with a second representation
module eight and the prefrontal cortex
is talking to crust to the lateral
cerebellum to newly evolved part of the
cerebellar cortex from there the monkey
studies of connectivity we're going to
jump forward to imaging in people this
is a series of studies done look my best
looking at where in the ceremony there
is activation as you lie in the scanner
during particular tasks the first was a
meta-analysis of a number of studies
previously published that shows of the
coronal Butte of the cerebellum of
people this is many studies together
mapped onto the snare better address
that there's a motor activation when you
leave on your fingers in the anterior
and Louisville 8 which we not expect but
language processing activates module 6
station processing activates the
cerebellum on the left side and also in
the midline and working memory activates
in the posterior of bilateral so we have
a suggestion from the imager that
overlays what we saw in the monkey
connectivity of a dichotomy of function
motor phenomenology and larval 3 to 5 in
the anterior both encouraging local 6
and most of module 8 and language
spatial and working memory in the
postive of each with its own topographic
organization in a single person lying in
the scanner you get the same results and
similarly in a group of results of nine
subjects in the scanner group together
we see the motor phenomena and your
primary and secondary language
processing in the cerebral Hemisphere on
the right here this is on the right 706
request one spatial processing and
working memory bilaterally in the
posterior
further we find that the motor system in
the cerebral cortex talks 2.45 and
modules in particular and the
Association is proposed a right I'll
drop them to the module six and seven in
this area a nice dichotomy of motor
still with the imaging will not have the
ability to use resting state functional
connectivity and by this we use the
fluctuation of blood flow the blood part
should level
and signal and we looked at how the
signal in different parts of the brain
oscillates and those regions that
oscillate in synchrony are thought to be
functionally coupled and enough from the
work of a Buckner and Wang mothers and a
range of investigators across the world
now that there is a sensory motor system
there is a our age we come to providing
network and the red is a default mode
network thoughts of attentional in green
a virtual attention in purple and the
salience network senior more than me
over to little middle prefrontal areas
so that's the networks after necessarily
hemisphere was extraordinarily
interesting and important now as you go
forwards is that these networks map onto
the circle and they do serve in the way
that is not predictable where we have
again in the anterior of the mobile age
the reflection of the sensory motor
networks whereas the more high order
areas involved in visual attention in
default mode Network and thinking
planning organizing creativity
strategies those are all coming down to
the post year cerebellar hemispheres and
differentiating that from the sensory
motor vehicle s my students as they did
well working with John Garey le
and the MIT lab has taken the Buckner
work further and shown the following
that whereas we have from resting state
connectivity a suggestion of a primary
and secondary motor representation as we
know from the work of smiler many years
ago there is an addition a primary
secondary and tertiary representation of
cognitive processing and using the large
data set many hundreds of people in the
human connectome project being able to
identify that in fact this primary and
secondary representation of the motor
system is there in the connector project
but also Jeff for higher level
processing a primary secondary and
tertiary level representation of
cognitive processing not only in the
resting state networks but also in tasks
based activity what the implications are
of the primary secondary and tertiary
representations happens to be real that
remains to be shown but the fact that
these exist gives us stronger
information that in fact is a
representation throughout the server in
the human of cognitive and emotionally
relevant areas that need to be further
understood but the level of functional
organization and clinical phenomenon we
now know about the networks in the
survey hemispheres and the networks in
the cerebellum but you can take this a
step further to look at the interaction
between these two regions cerebral
cortex and servo worked with my
colleagues at the Beth Israel Deaconess
Medical Center here in Boston
Marc Alto and Fahrenheit for them
showing that if you stimulate the
cerebellar vermis
you change the dorsal attention Network
upstairs so you can modulate to
transpile magnetic stimulation the
cerebellar focal areas and change
networks up in the cerebral hemispheres
but if you move to the lateral servo the
network you change is a default mode
network the network that's active when
you're not doing anything in particular
your brain is I think or thinking or
creating or being in a space of
mindfulness so you can change your
network upstairs depending on where you
stimulate and survive very much in line
with the idea of functional topography
in the survival furthermore and we'll
come back to this in the theory
discussion at the end is that when he
stimulates the vermis versus the lateral
hemispheres you change the different
networks in the same direction so the
EEG looking at the temporal dynamics of
the processing
changes in the same direction in other
words you affect different networks in
the same direction by stimulating
different places in the cerebellum
well that's all good and well what
happens if you go to the bedside and you
actually spend time with patients to
look to see what are the manifestations
of all of the cerebellum neurobiology in
patients with cerebellar dysfunction I'm
going to start somewhat out of
chronological sequence with work that
looked at the old question of structure
function correlation in brain
organization if you have a stroke in a
particular part of the brain one can get
an understanding of what it is that that
part of the brain does by studying the
deficits that result so this is a stroke
on a scan called diffusion-weighted
imaging the bright spot bright spot is
the stroke in the area that's called the
superior cerebellar distribution and
that irrigates the anterior lobe what we
not think of as a motifs airbone and
this producers on the ataxia rating
scale evidence of the problem with
control of the arm of the leg of gait
perhaps of speech and our movements
that's the cerebellum motor center but
if you have a stroke of similar size and
the tempt are irrigated by the posterior
inferior cerebellar artery which is on
the cognitive cerebellum not the motor
region there is in fact on the ataxia
rating scale was no evidence that they
tax yet but something else and we've
shown the same thing more recently with
voxel based Jesus into mapping and here
when the patients with a stroke involve
the anterior here in the coronal image
or in the saddle image of the top of the
serve on the motor regions or the
cemetery deposit is new case in
particular these people have the
cerebellar motor syndrome ataxia
dysarthria this Metreon ocular motor
abnormalities on the other hand when the
stroke spares the anterior lobe and the
stroke involves the poster of
yeah seen here in the circle image or on
the actual image these folks do not have
the motor syndrome they have the
syndrome I'm gonna spend some time
talking about now which is a set of
cognitive factors so many years ago when
I began realizing that the theory that
we have proposed in the mind in the
1980s about cerebellar contribution to
cognition the neck area needed to be
matched by an ER behavioral coroner to
the patient's we did what clinicians do
we go to the bedside and we ask our
patients by examining them what is this
that we think that part of the brain is
actually doing and this is young a young
woman we have a cerebellar tumor
receptive the tomb was described
discovered when she slipped on ice and
she fell hit a hand at a scan that
showed the tumor tumor taken out and
she's able to stand and walk normally
and took okay there was no problem
controllable arms or legs but she had a
personality change and she was referred
to us by the nurses who conducted the
neurosurgeons that there was a change in
this young woman she was being trialed
ich disrobing in the car door was hiding
under the bed covers deepening and
talking inappropriately and with very
old-fashioned simple tests of cognition
at the bedside we identified the fact
that she was I'm able to bisect the line
and did serve multiple times isn't
called perseveration which has seen a
patient with frontal lobe disorder she
was unable to draw a clock even when the
outline was drawn for her that's a
visual spatial of disorganization and
when asked to write a sentence she wrote
this rameters of mine
the 23rd with was after separation in
her words this in one slide is
essentially the features that came to
describe the syndrome the Sierra
cognitive affective simple and you
looked at patients over the years and we
came up with a clinical school which
identify the severity of the deficits we
showed that executive function reasoning
calculation and effective changes were
most prominent on the effect of changes
were occurring and patients hadn't
applying tunisians there was some
difficulty with visual spatial function
of the rubber memory and language
processing but for the remainder they
were not too badly impaired and my
colleague Janet Sherman took these folks
into neuro psychology laboratory and
identified on these graphs a zero is
normal this is one two and three
standard deviations below or about the
mean that there were problems with the
executive function spatial cognition
verbal and visual memory and as a group
patients into Metro function was pushed
off to the left or impaired as you'll
see there are some folks who are fine
within one standard deviation above or
below the mean and these are people
whose lesions were rather smaller when
both will have better anterior those
whose problems were primarily cognitive
a phonemic fluency tell us how many
words can you name that begin before
that F or a yes or the gray complex
diagram the copying and remembering of a
visual figure or verbal and visual
memory these are the folks who lesions
were large over-involved the Sarah
posterior lower right from the get-go
the cerebellar cognitive affective
syndrome of executive function spatial
image language deficits and personality
change all were related to damage to the
Sarah posterior and the executive
function problem to do the planning
section and verbal fluency after
working memory deficits the spatial
cognition has you've seen this visual
spatial organization and recall a
grandma there's only difficulty with the
syntax of language a perso dia
immaculate change in the modulation of
speech and difficulty finding words in
conversation and a remarkable
personality change from lesions of the
midline with abducting adapted from the
one hand or disinhibition and
inappropriate behavior on the other the
syndrome Nam was described as the third
cornerstone of chemical attacks geology
on my colleagues along with the other
two the cerebellar motor syndrome and
the said vestibular this is an important
clinical feature to the extent that the
National air taxi foundation has a fact
sheet on cognition and emotion instead
mental disorders to give patients an
awareness and understanding that the
problems at Iran are these high order
functions is not a factor of them being
depressed well as being in their head
but it's actually a problem of being in
their brain something's happened to the
neural substrates that are relevant for
cognition and emotion this work has been
replicated now over the past two decades
throughout institutions across the world
in a number of different circumstances
and I'll show you just a couple this is
one they came out of work from the group
here looking at multiple sclerosis his
long denote the multiple sclerosis
effect to survive but it's thought to
have been important for the motor
control what the group has showed is
that the mapping of the white matter
lesions in the cerebellum as you see
having all cases in a coronal image of
the middle cerebellar theory those
patients in veneers preservation of
cognitive performance have much less
involved into the middle cerebellar
peduncle than those who are cognitively
impaired and the reason this is
important is the middle cerebellar
peduncle that i showed you earlier is
the conduit or where the information
from the cerebral hemisphere is conveyed
into the ceremony
you've also shown a few tweaks on the
original observation that the language
impairments actually are not only a
grand prism and an onion and sometimes
the stuttering as well as the dysarthria
that you see in several patients but
there's a problem with the use of
language to convey thoughts and to
interpret the meanings of others
submitter linguistics the use of
ambiguity when things aren't entirely
clear instead misses or inferences that
you mean something else other than what
you've actually said well the metaphor
using examples to explain something else
well the ability to express oneself in a
grammatically correct manner and
appropriate to context these
metalinguistic functions are not
preserved in patients with cerebellar
injury over and above any difficulty
they may have with the clarity of the
articulation and similarly as my system
Xavier showing us that there was a
problem of theory of money the ability
to interpret and understand the kind of
thoughts of somebody else may have and
that's important so important for
regulating behavior within a social
context and it turns out to be
irrelevant in people who have a quiet
cerebellar injuries as well and this has
relevance for patients in their own life
and in social interactions a couple of
years after the first paper came out
that when we described the cognitive
active syndrome he published the work
that had been ongoing for a while of
children who had said about tumors per
second
tumors mustard on of the commonest
location for brain tumors in children
and has an example of the medieval
Osterman that has been receptive in the
trial after surgery and we showed the
same thing in the kids in the attempt to
copy
recall and then later on recall the
complex figure we see a marked
fragmentation
of the response of this youngster with a
cerebellar to the point being that the
children had tumors taken out in the
absence of radiation and the absence of
drugs that can affect the brain
structure like methotrexate there were
the same issues problem-solving
difficulty organizing verbal or visual
spatial material impairment of planning
of organizing language difficulties long
agencies poor initiation short responses
unable to elaborate on from the context
of a sentence trouble with finding words
when naming things memory impaired for
stories federalism prompting and a
dramatic change in a regulation of the
athlete with the cerebellum midline was
involved with vermis meters so
irritability impulsivity disinhibition
and they are ethnic or part of the
syndrome and this is somewhat similar to
the difficulty described across the
world in children with several tumors
respectively where there is a cerebellum
mutism syndrome children stopped talking
for a few days sometimes four months
after the midline surgery and the
cerebellum mutism may be associated with
the cerebellar cognitive affective
syndrome the cerebellum ODIs and brain
stem destruction and other issues of
cranial neuropathy from brain stem
regions so the Unison may occur in the
setting of a cognitive affective
syndrome but they don't always go
together and you can have the calm that
I think of syndrome even with office
here but I'm using but this is a major
issue for pediatric neurosurgery which
is not being addressed directly by the
surgeons to try and find ways to
minimize damage to cerebellum
when they go in and get the tumors out
to say these children's lives I'll
describe for you a rare experiment of
nature
this is cerebellar agenesis it's more
likely a disruption of a seraph
everybody on in utero early life as
opposed to some gene disorder these
cases are rare they're only a few of
them in the world we have about ten
patients here in our own group and we'll
be hearing about those in the future
there was no cerebellum back here in the
Padre fossa and the brainstem is
flattened because the pons is normally
quite nicely round and that's where the
neurons sending information to serve
atom are located so that whole system is
not present in people who have a Genesis
this is an example of a man who'd been
following our familiarity with the
z-score distribution on the summit one
can see that there is an apparent an
eroded natural function in mark and then
the visuospatial function in phonemic
fluency and then the executive function
tasks using trails a and B the problem
described in the people that we saw was
six-pack denim in 2002 it was difficult
to an executive impairments spatial
cognition language processing and
psychiatric were effective changes the
vorticity performances and some of these
folks obsessive reach Originals
difficulty with social cues all of it
speaks to a social cognition if you'd
like to log on to National Public Radio
and you type in a Genesis you will find
the very nice report describing this
young man in the report that had myself
in German describing his case and
carving his own story among his family
in his own words and present some color
and some vibrancy to the nature of the
phenomenon
Experion
people who live without ceremony still
in the pediatric realm it's important to
note that when children have images in
the cerebellum early on there are some
neurological difficulties to using tone
modem a communication deficits visual
problems expressive language but they
are almost in a variety of behavioral
and social activities with autism scores
and fully 40% or more of these
youngsters so a cerebellar damage as an
isolated phenomenon very own needs to
arrange not only of motor problems and
of cognitive social emotional problems
as well and this leads into the next way
to think about cerebellum in this role
beyond modes if you look at disorders
are defined by the neuropsychiatry not
the cerebellum motor system about the
neuropsychiatry such thing does
attention deficit disorder
dyslexia of infants born great preacher
autism schizophrenia there is a long and
non-growing
neuroscience that links airbone to need
disorders for example autism went back
to the 1980s was shown to have most of
the normal pump neurons deep down in the
so Berman and Kemper hypothesized at
that time that the cerebellum was
important in the generation of the
symptoms and the phenomena that
characterized 30 in and with more recent
work now coming out of Children's
Hospital in Boston using the true versus
neurosis complex as a mouse model of
autism we see abnormal social
interaction and repetitive behaviors in
that mouse model I'll come back to that
in a second schizophrenia has new
information pointing to its relationship
to survival not just a margin for the
fourth ventricle prominence with
cerebellar fissures or lack of normally
symmetry but we now see in payments and
cerebellar frontal interactions and we
see in people who are at risk of
cerebellum biscuits
that the cerebellum is actually smaller
on voxel-based morphometry studies and
do not have some work coming out of my
previous post doc and the train care
Boston demonstrated that there is a
relationship between cerebellum and
autism in the human and in the mouse
model is an ongoing work representative
of the evolving field of science of
cerebellar neuropsychiatry across one
over here in the latter part of the
cerebellum is irrelevant in autism they
are identifying in autism spectrum
disorder folks in that area and there is
a payment of a functionally connected
circuits in importance in spectrum
disorder in healthy controls modulation
of the cerebellum in the right cross one
affects the connectivity with the
inferior parietal lobule
and there is a typical functional
connectivity in that disorder as well in
the mouse model there is impaired
connectivity between the right plus one
and the parietal lobe and you can change
the activity and the behavior of the
mouse by stimulation or inhibition of
right across one so we have now an
evolving field of the neurobiology
in the neural circuitry of cerebellum as
relationship to these primary and
neuropsychiatric disorders autism and
schizophrenia
prime emotional similarly when you look
at patients who have classical
neurodegenerative a taxes and you study
the serotonin
they are some remarkably and you can
find it we now know that if you do
boxful based Jesus into mapping and look
at the morphology the cerebellum and
Alzheimer's disease and in front of
temporal dementia there was Regional
atrophy in the cerebellum in crest when
it comes to in all genres and in Ludlow
16 and
temporal dementia that are linked with
the cerebral cortex areas that atrophy
and those diseases so we now bring the
network idea of cerebus a better
interaction into play not only when the
disease starts in ceremony but when the
disease we think starts in the southern
hemisphere so the question now is is the
cerebellum of these disorders as well as
just a bystander or doesn't actually
have relevance and when you do a review
of all time the disease it turns out to
be a strong and robust history of
cerebellar involvement in that disease
of um uh pay attention to I'm sure that
talked about neuropsychiatry and this
rolling
cerebellar role in that what I I'll
share with you now is that if you look
at patients who have cerebellar injury
when find to survive and you look at the
behaviors that are manifesting in that
group there is a range of behaviors of
four within five domains of
neuropsychiatric regulation attentional
control emotional control autism
spectrum disorders psychosis spectrum
disorders and social skill set and all
the symptoms have mapped onto those five
domains seem to have an exaggerated
overshoot or hypo metric field and a
negative diminished or metric
competitive so like the motor system
issues and if you we think that in the
neuropsychiatric domain it's also that
was an undershoot within these five
domains of behavior we have taken those
symptoms and developed a preliminary
version of a scale to assess a
neurocircuitry and folks who have
several disorders among the domains of
attention emotion what is the spectrum
psychosis
my social skill set and applied this in
the memory way which I'll share with you
today this is a young man who we heard
about with what sounded like the first
big schizophrenia between the ages of 14
and 17 yet progressive decline in school
ability progressive school failure and
rumination change in his ability to
interact with others loss of empathy
progressive internalization of the
sports and the family was worried about
him when the psychiatrist he was taking
care for me became concerned that he had
headaches along with his constipation
and so he had a scan and the scan
demonstrated of a Chiari malformation
with the the you have got a lot of mind
pulled right down below it should be an
assist in the spinal cord centers and
after amongst years of conversation with
his parents and his caregivers we
decided to take him into surgery mostly
because this was that this meets Waller
criteria for surgical said to be
treatable Chiari malformation but before
we did we did this study psychiatric a
rating scale and in a graph form where a
0 to maybe 4 or 5 would be normal he was
scoring very high on that scale for the
total score and the positive and
negative symptoms scale of a seven ears
like that a grading scale and within the
month off the surgery the graph looked
like that so I've been in this case as a
work in progress but there's something
about both the phenomenology or Kyary
the neuropsychiatric features and the
scale to pick it up that needs to be
explored as we go forwards and that's
one of the reasons I'm talking about
this today so we can try and promote
further work in the field across the
Pacific one of the missing pieces in the
analysis of cognition imitation is
cerebellar injury the ability to
determine without spending the whole day
in the lab what the behavior is can we
identify the cognitive impairments and
how to do sir
so working with my team we performed
full neuropsychological
a large number of patients and controls
we derived those tests that seem to be
most predictive of pathology in those
patients and those patients you
identified that will test vary from that
group and then we validated that scale
another series of patients and there'll
be controllers but this is not a
cerebellar cognitive affective schmow
man syndrome scale this is published in
brain just months ago and it's available
for use it looks at categories that are
most predictive of figuring out whether
a person who has these problems with a
patient or a survey for healthy
controllers care about a patient were
healthy control so the test is selective
but not yet sensitive not get specific
semantics phonemic and category
switching fluency
a verbal recall to disband forwards and
backwards cube joining the copping
similarities they go no the
transcriptase inhibition and a sense of
the effective range of the patients
before so this should allow us to
examine patients in the clinical setting
in a ten minute screen to determine
whether or not a patient with a ser
about a problem in fact has a cerebellar
cognitive affective syndrome and I
invite you to use that so let's wrap
this up with some concepts back in the
late nineteen eighties when I was
putting this all together as a way to go
forwards we proposed the dysmetria of
thought theory and the theory of in the
same way the cerebellum regulates motor
control
so does it do that to Harnett would have
function the rate rhythm force and
accuracy of movements are matched in the
high order domain by speed consistency
capacity and appropriateness of mental
or cognitive processes so in other words
what the cerebellum is doing to motor
control is doing
everything else and the idea about
predictability and the logic to social
and societal interaction matches on maps
of wealth and matches the kind of trip
difficulties I've been describing in the
patients that we can see over the last
almost four decades we then need to move
from theory to therapy and given that
the cerebellum we think is modulating
behaviors trying to improve
neuropsychiatric phenomena we worked
with a patient population of
schizophrenia very difficult to control
difficult to treat this is refractory
patients a small group was a prefect
principal study in which we stimulated
the back of the set of the vermis what
we think is the central feature of the
Lu become Tibetan let's come back that
and second to see if we could produce
improvements in the well-being of
patients with schizophrenia and what we
saw is that when the positive and
negative symptoms of schizophrenia
there's an improvement in the negative
symptoms which is difficult to do with
the better times depression improved and
the sense of happiness sadness and
alertness all improved by the patient's
subjective report after the continuous
performance tasks which is a chest of
attention so that's an attempt to bring
the therapy therapy from the initial
theory and this work has now been taken
up by others around the world and
there's a new approach to treatment
using neuromodulation that targeting
staredown the president's wide
connectivity to multiple regions of the
cognitive and limbic cerebral
hemispheres in order to try and improve
outcomes in patients with these very
debilitating disorders so let me go back
to this young women are presented with
the outset after years of inability to
speak and
normally ends the word she came to us
with the parents asking to asking us for
help and another two months in rehab
didn't make a difference and so we tried
brain stimulation with transcranial
magnetic stimulation and after a week of
the stimulation applied to the
cerebellar vermis there was a remarkable
improvement in their constellation she's
able to get up and start speaking and
start walking and take food by mouth and
put clothes on eventually go back to
school and get on the Dean's List at
school still the sub motor in pens but a
marked improvement and I think what this
does it opens the question for us as a
field what is it that transparent
magnetic stimulation does to jumpstart
the process of recovery is there a role
for neuro motivation coming in via Sarah
to improve upstairs neural circuits and
do we have a new way to treat people who
we couldn't treat before using
cerebellum and the theories and the new
information and knowledge the Box have
on based on this work and the work
around the world that has evolved in
this new exciting field of the cognitive
neuroscience part of the cerebellum so
then we come back to the theory about
how this is all put together because if
you have an understanding of how this
works then the understanding can deepen
using patience and using patient
response we can also have somewhere to
put our observations it's no longer a
puzzle or whether questions continue we
have a framework within which to think
about the cerebellar contribution to
higher function and it starts off like
this remember the slide the beginning
about the distributive neural networks
necessarily hemispheres
well the cerebellum is an integral node
in those networks in the distributed
neural circuits upstairs and downstairs
that's observed sensory motor function
cognitive processing what's anomic
function they haven't talked about now
and the effective regulation and
remember that the cerebellar cortex is
essentially homogeneous throughout but
the connections are different from that
what the cerebellum is doing is
to the different system since your motor
cognitive and limbic but it's doing the
same thing there's a topography of
behavior there's a sensory motor strive
element bought before and fired on the
Tapia model 8 down the bottom and then
the stimulus Tibet on the Marvel 10 and
part of my own mind but the cognitive
affective cerebellum is there a huge
expanse of the human cerebellar bubble
six across one crust to explore
cognitive and affective and there's a
medial to manner of topography where the
midline is the Olympics air about the
vestigial ninjas and the firmest this is
the autonomic regulation effect in post
emotion important memory and their
hemispheres are the executive visual
spatial linguistic learning parts of
ceremony there's a cognitive limbic
dichotomy when limping his midline
cognitive is allowed the homogeneity of
cerebellar cortex is important but isn't
at the level of an atom even at the
level of theory that is Danny how this
works
the idea is that the architecture of
cerebellum is consistent throughout
allowing it to do one thing that's the
universal cerebellar transformed its
harmful nation is modified in survival
it's the computation of the cerebellar
cortex our idea is that the cerebellum
optimizes performance by modulating
behavior around a homeostatic basically
it doesn't make things and make things
better it does it automatically
implicitly without conscious awareness
but according to context so that's what
the cerebellum is doing is keeping
things where they should be a perfect
according to contract the anatomic
specificity of the removal of the
circuits are described and lastly them
to continue to multiple domains of
processing throughout the spectrum of
human behavior the corroboree though is
that the cerebellum breaks down that you
break down the same way as well it does
one thing if you break down the same way
and that's the idea of just metria so
these into the sensory motor cerebellum
produced
Smith movement or the cerebellar motor
syndrome and lesions of the cognitive
Olympic cerebellum to use dis Mitra of
thought and emotion for the cerebellar
cognitive factors there are many
implications of this work what's so
exciting and gratifying for me through
the years now almost 40 years into this
is that there's a whole field of
cognitive neuroscience looking
specifically at these questions
brightest of the young investigators
coming up and the extraordinary new
technology allows us to take this to a
new level of Investigation which will
feed back on patients and patient care
because there's a range of direct
implications for people who deal with
cerebellar diseases in particular that
neuropsychiatry
in general it was a need-to-know
imperative the cognitive affective
syndrome is not in their head it's in
their brain there's a brain problem
resulting in these behavioral issues
once we know that as the field of
medicine caring for these folks and
neurologists need to notice the
recognition can lead to intervention
because now there are windows for
cognitive rehab and past cross-modal
therapies and as I showed you with that
young woman and what the Kinari patient
that in primary or psychiatric diseases
bipartisan let's get Sofia and maybe
even beyond as I described in
Alzheimer's in their frontal temporal
there is a role for the cerebellum in
the pathophysiology of these disorders
and they are now new opportunities for
treatment novel strategies for
intervention that were inconceivable and
so we have changed our thinking we have
this revolution in thinking about said
that I'm not as motor control device
that has said that am is critical for
the modulation of all behaviors so that
I'm doing its thing flying's transform
to the multiple ranges of behaviors
across the domains of the human spectrum
of behavior so I'll end with that and
just make sure that we pay attention to
the folks that we work with through the
years this kind of work is collaborative
it
canary we learned from mentors and we
learned from our students in there for
my patients I want to pay tribute to all
the folks who work with me and my lab
through the years to reach this point in
time so I will be happy to answer
questions that come through the email
system as we go and for those who are
interested in this field which is
perhaps not the most exciting fields in
neuroscience today I would welcome you
into that and it for to ongoing dialogue
with those of you out there who are
interested in stem and in serving on
their biology and neuropsychology thank
you very much thank you dr. Spellman for
that informative presentation I would
also like to thank lab roots for making
this educational webcast possible before
we go I want everyone know that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through June 2018 that's all for
now thank you for joining us we hope to
see you again soon goodbye